>> THERE IS MORE FALLOUT FOR
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
AFTER THE REPORT FOUND OUT HE
VIOLATED PROTOCOL LEAKING MEMOS
OF HIS PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT TOLD HIM ON
TWITTER HE GOT LUCK BEHE AVOIDED
PROSECUTION.
IS THE WORST TO COME FOR
DIRECTOR COMEY?
REPUBLICANS THINK SO.
>> I WON'T APOLOGIZE.
JAMES COMEY OWES THE COUNTRY AN
APOLOGY.
WE KNOW HE DID IT BECAUSE HE WAS
OUT TO GET THE PRESIDENT.
>> JAMES COMEY HAD A PERSONNEL
VENDETTA.
HE BELIEVES HIS ROLE IN THE FBI
WAS ONE HE WAS THE ULTIMATE
JUDGE AND JURY ON ANYTHING HE
DID OR DID NOT LIKE.
>> ONLY IN WASHINGTON, D.C. CAN
YOU HAVE 70 PLUS PAGES OF BAD
NEWS AND EXPECT AN APOLOGY.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT
WILL BE MORE DAMNING THAN THIS.
>> I STILL HAVE A BONE TO PICK
WITH DIRECTOR COMEY.
GREG, SHOULD HE BE PROSECUTED
FOR LEAKING MEMOS AFTER BEING
FIRED?
>> THAT GOES BACK TO MY INITIAL
POINT.
YOU CAN'T TRUST TALL PEOPLE.
SHORT PEOPLE ARE MORE TRUST
WORTHY AND MORE DOWN-TO-EARTH.
WE DON'T PULL THIS CRAP.
THE REAL JACK ASSES ARE THE
MEDIA THAT PAINTED HIM AS A
CROSS.
HE WAS THEIR TOOL.
HE AND McCABE ARE GETTING A GAME
SHOW ON CNN, CALLED LEAK, LOSE
OR DRAW.
>> HE IS GETTING A TASTE OF HIS
OWN MEDICINE.
HE SAID ALL OF THE THINGS ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON.
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING ONE.
HE HAS NO CONSTITUENCY
HE HAS NO CONSTITUENIE
HE HAS NO CONSTITUECOE
HE HAS NO CONSTITUECONSTITUENCIS
HE HAS NO CONSTITUECONSTITUENCI.
HE ALIENATED A LOT OF PEOPLE.
I READ A LENGTHY DEFENSE OF THE
DECISION NOT TO PROSECUTE AND
THESE WERE PERSONAL MEMOS.
I HAVE A HARD TIME BELIEVING
THAT.
IF YOU TAKE NOTES ABOUT A
CONVERSATION YOU HAVE WITH YOUR
BOSS AND YOU SAY THAT THOSE ARE
NOT GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS, I FIND
THAT REALLY HARD TO BELIEVE.
IT FELT TO ME IN THE DEFENSE I
READ ABOUT JAMES COMEY, WELL, WE
COULD SEE THAT.
I HAVE A FEELING IF IT WENT THE
OTHER WAY, THEY COULD HAVE
WRITTEN IT IN THE SAME WAY.
I THINK WASHINGTON IS GLAD TO BE
FINISHED WITH THIS.
REPUBLICANS THAT ARE SAYING IT
WILL BE WORSE FOR COMEY.
IT RAISES SUSPICIONS HOW
INDEPENDENT IS THE PROBE?
MAYBE THEY GET REGULAR UPDATES.
THEY SHOULD NOT TALK ABOUT IT.
>> I WANT HIM TO GET A TASTE OF
HIS OWN MEDICINE.
HE SAID ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON,
EXTREMELY CARELESS IN HANDLING
HIGHLY CLASSIFIED INFO.
WE WENT BACK TO HIS OFFICE AND
EVERY TIME HE HAD AN INTERACTION
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP HE TYPED UP
A MEMO.
WHEN HE WAS FIRED HE SHOULD HAVE
TURNED IT OVER.
HE LEAKED ONE MEMO TO A REPORTER
BECAUSE HE FELT THAT NOBODY WAS
GOING FORWARD TO TELL THE TRUTH
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED.
GIVE ME YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
THIS.
>> THE ONLY THING HE DIDN'T HAVE
WAS [INAUDIBLE].
BUT HE HAD A SAFE.
PEOPLE SAY LIBERTARIANS ARE
AFRAID OF GOVERNMENT.
JAMES COMEY SHOWS HOW PEOPLE WHO
LOSE THEIR POWER, HOW THEY
REACT.
THE FACT HE DID ALL OF THIS
LEAKING TO GET A SPECIAL COUNSEL
IS THE MOST CONCERNING THING.
HE TOLD US THIS ENTIRE TIME, BE
CAREFUL THAT THE INSTITUTIONS
WILL BE DESTROYED.
HE DESTROYED THE FBI.
THE IG SAID THE EXAMPLE THAT
JAMES COMEY SET FOR THE OTHER
HUNDREDS AND THOUSANDS OF FBI
AGENTS WAS A BAD EXAMPLE.
A DANGEROUS PRECEDENT.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE CONCERNED.
>> HE VIOLATED HIS EMPLOYMENT
AGREEMENT.
THAT'S CLEAR.
THE 35,000 MEN AND WOMEN WHO
REPRESENT THE FBI UNDERSTAND
THAT WHEN THEY SIGNED THAT OATH
TO TAKE THAT JOB, THEY SHOULD
SUPPORT THE FBI.
DO YOU THINK HE WAS ACTING AS A
WHISTLE BLOWER?
>> NO, I DON'T.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IN THE REPORT
THEY SAID HE WAS NOT A WHISTLE
BLOWER.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT ONE.
YOUR POINTS --
>> WHAT ABOUT MINE?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I AM A TALL
GIRL.
>> WHAT I LOVE ABOUT YOUR POINT,
THE DEFENSE OF COMEY HAS NO
BASIS IN THE ACTUAL REPORT
ITSELF.
IN TERMS OF HIS CALLING IT A
PERSONAL RECORD, THE IG SAID IT
WAS INCOMPATIBLE WITH PLAIN
LANGUAGE WITH HIM LEAKING THE
REPORT.
HE SAID I DID IT BECAUSE I LOVE
THE NATION.
HE SAID YOUR WHOLE TEAM CALLED
IT SHOCKING AND SURPRISING
REGARDING THE 36,000 PEOPLE IN
THE FBI, THE IG SAID IF THEY
FOLLOW YOUR EXAMPLE THE FBI
WOULD NOT UNABLE TO, TO PERFORM
ITS ROLE OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEI G SAID THIS IS NOT ROOTED
IN SANITY.
>> HE SAID THERE WAS A LEGAL
PATHWAY IF YOU WANT TO BE A
WHISTLE BLOWER AND YOU IGNORED
IT.